you know Knox has so much scale in the
size when it is put in emphatically by
chris boucher so god can make plays and
there's chris boucher active effing saw
mitchell robinson lead the block show
last summer he did not shoot well here
at the summer league in las vegas but
ended up having a terrific rookie season
and then of course Steph Curry an MVP he
didn't shoot very well in summer legato
again we have chris boucher moving his
way to the the bucket and scoring plus
the foul so here's RJ working against
Thomas determined to get to the cup and
he says silence about this missed three
driving and look at the strength for
size this two tournament takes the hit
might have got my big out of Oregon
going against Boucher about soo big out
of Oregon
RJ Barrett yes plus the foul out one
left and obviously he's got to work on a
counter to going right but this is just
taking up the space creating the bump
and then good pass Boucher
join the slain a Volusia and the Knicks
are within nine nice pass to Boucher who
flashed on the baseline and hit the Jay
that's a tough shot make it look pretty
watch chris boucher look baseline
quickly gets it off that's a tough shot
see for years the basketball Smitty and
they finally got the gold ball there's a
wonderful job that is a total team
therefore there's you shitty wow he has
18 the town of the shot clock Fernandez
shuffle defeat a little bit got it back
and here's a tweet get him to the line
for a possible three points will execute
and sharing the basketball and not only
that when you start to play for others
Hernandez and the rebound by RJ Barrett
has 9 rebounds and RJ Barrett looks at
it rebound on the ball pushed it
surveying the court driving it
take it away in my left I go right to
the right this was an NBA game he's got
a chance to play the NBA games it'd be
totally different for everyone be as it
as aggressive but he has a high motor
and some ability of those are two really
well and bare we know that whole story
but two on Hernandez really catching
eyes here as Barrett scores for the
Knicks they trailed by 32 go with 13
points and 13 boards Barrett he hit a
three ladies and gentlemen